---
Devil fruits: The utlimate power system in One
Piece. And today we’re going to talk about every
single devil fruit that has officially appeared
in the series so far based on the mangahb.
Starting with all Zoan type devil fruits.
This category of fruits allows the user to
transform into an animal, granting
them immense strength and stamina
and depending on the fruit some
unique bonus abilities as well.
**Ushi Ushi**
1. **Bison Dalton**
And at number one, we have a pretty
straight forward transformation. Dalton, the King
of the Sakura Kingdom uses his Ushi Ushi no Mi:
Model Bison to turn into a Bison.
2. **Giraffe Kaku**
Kaku of CP9 on the other hand uses his
fruit to turn into a giraffe. You’d
think this would be a useless power, but
using his long neck as a counter balance,
he actually uses this transformation to
enhance his swordsmanship. Not sure why
it’s categorized as a cow fruit though. But as
you’ll see, a few fruits don’t really make sense.
**Hito Hito**
1. **Human Chopper
What’s better than being a cow? Turning
into a human being.** Chopper is a reindeer
who ate the Hito-Hito no Mi, the human human
fruit. Presumably this fruit would be absolutely
useless if a human ate it (or if the SBS is to
be believed, they might gain enlightenment), but
in Chopper’s case he gained the ability to walk,
talk, and have a human intellect.
2. **Buddha Sengoku**
The former Fleet Admiral of the Marines,
Sengoku, uses the Daibutsu fruit to transform
into a giant Golden Buddha, making for a very
intimidating presence on the battlefield.
1. **Onyudo Onimaru**
Sticking with Japanese Mythology, Onimaru is a
komagitsune - a type of mythical fox. However,
this is unrelated to his devil fruit. The Onyudo
fruit allows Onimaru to transform into an Onyudo
- a type of giant monk yokai. Like Chopper,
this fruit grants Onimaru the ability to speak.
1. **Nika Luffy**
Well, what do you know? We’re only 6
fruits in and we’ve already gotten to
our main character. For years Oda lead
to us to believe that Luffy had the
Gomu Gomu no Mi. In reality, though, his
fruit was actually the Hito Hito no Mi:
Model Nika. Mythical Zoan fruits like this
allow the user to turn into a mythological
creature and these imbue some of the greatest
powers in all of One Piece. This fruit for
example grants Luffy the powers of the Sun God
NIka, nicknamed the “Toon Force” by the fandom,
which are seemingly only
limited by his imagination.
And the most powerful human type devil fruit of
all is of course the subscriber subscriber no mi,
eaten by you, after destroy the
subscribe button below this video.
**Tori Tori**
1. **Falcon Pell**
Next we have the birds. Pell,
one of Princess Vivi’s guardians in Alabasta
can transform into a falcon, allowing for super
fast flight. His hybrid form makes Pell looks
like Horus, the falcon-headed god of Egyptian
mythology. The jury’s still out on whether
falcons can withstand nuclear weapons, though,
like Pell did at the end of the arc.
2. **Phoenix Marco**
One of the coolest fruits in the entire series is
Marco’s Phoenix fruit. Whitebeard’s first division
commander, Marco, is also the doctor of the crew,
which works out because the Phoenix fruit’s flames
allow him to heal himself and others.
3. **Albatross Morgans**
For some reason, Big News Morgans, who
always keeps in his hybrid albatross form,
cannot fly. Ironic, given that real world
albatrosses are known for their extremely
long flights across the sea. Good thing he has
those news coos to deliver the papers for him.
**Inu Inu**
10 **Dachshund Lasso (Cannon)**
Moving on to men’s best friend and all the
doggos. Starting with Lasso of Baroque Works,
who is not a dog who ate a cannon fruit. He’s
actually a cannon who was fed the Inu Inu no Mi:
Model Dachshund. This character was the very first
instance of learning that inanimate
objects could be fed devil fruits.
1. **Jackal Chaka**
Chaka is the other zoan guardian
of Alabasta. His hybrid form
makes him look like the Egyptian God
Anubis, who has a jackal for a head.
1. **Wolf Jabra**
Jabra of CP9 uses his devil fruit to
transform into a powerful wolf. In addition,
he loves using trickery and storytelling to try
and fool his victims, calling upon the many fairy
tales which feature a “Big Bad Wolf” such as
the Three Little Pigs or Little Red Riding Hood.
1. **Tanuki Bunbuku (teapot)**
Another inanimate object with a devil fruit,
Bunbuku is a teapot who ate a Tanuki fruit.
1. **Kitsune Catarina Devon**
Catarina Devon is one of Blackbeard’s
crewmates. With her Kitsune mythical zoan,
she can transform her appearance
to appear as someone else.
1. **Makami Yamato**
Yamato, Kaidou’s son, has a mythical zoan
that transforms him into the Okuchi no Makami,
a protector of Wano who
possesses ice-based powers.
**Neko Neko**
1. **Leopard Lucci**
And after dogs come of course
cats. Lucci, the powerhouse of CP9,
uses his leopard transformation to gain
immense strength, dexterity, and agility.
1. **Saber-Toothed Tiger Who's who**
Who’s Who, the former member of CP9, fits right
in with the beast Pirates with his Saber-Toothed
Tiger zoan. Like many of his crewmates, his
ancient devil fruit is based on an extinct animal.
**Zou Zou**
1. **Elephant Funkfreed**
Which brings us over to 2 elephant
fruits. Yet another inanimate object
with a devil fruit power, Funkfreed
is a sword who can transform into
an extremely cute elephant. I
mean, just look at those eyes.
1. **Mammoth Jack**
And on the opposite side of
the cuteness spectrum is Jack,
one of Kaidou’s All Stars, is a
fishman who ate a Mammoth devil fruit.
**Ryu Ryu**
1. **Allosaurus X-Drake**
For some people this next one is definitely the
best category of animal to turn into: Dinosaurs.
Don’t get it twisted - Diez-Drake is
not a T-Rex. He’s an allosaurus. And
according to paleontologists those are two
different dinosaurs. Interestingly enough,
like all of the other dinosaur fruits to come on
this list - the fruit name is “Ryu Ryu”
which means “Dragon”, not “Dinosaur.”
1. **Spinosaurus Page One**
Page One’s Spinosaurus fruit is
yet another powerful dinosaur
transformation from one of the Tobi Roppo.
1. **Pteranodon King**
The All-Star King’s Pteranodon fruit is modeled
after a flying dinosaur significantly larger
than the pterodactyl. The most significant
power King’s fruit gives him is flight,
however, Oda’s mastery of biology teaches us
that they are also able to use their large
crests and beaks in a sling-shot
effect to utilize ranged attacks.
1. **Brachiosaurus Queen**
Queen, the last of Kaidou’s All-Stars we’re
covering, has a Brachiosaurus fruit. And yet
again, we get a science lesson from Oda that
states that Brachiosauruses can launch their
long neck and tail from the rest of their
body to become a snake-like creature. The
manga makes this very clear that this is not
one of Queen’s many cybernetic enhancements,
but a natural born ability of all Brachiosauruses.
1. **Pachycephalosaurus Ulti**
Ulti, one of the Tobiroppo, has a very
fitting dinosaur zoan transformation. The
Pachycephalosaurus literally means “thick-headed
lizard”, boasting a skull several times thicker
than any other dinosaur. Makes sense for the
most stubborn and “hard-headed” of Kaidou’s crew.
1. **Triceratops Sasaki**
The last of our Ryu Ryu no Mi fruits is
Sasaki’s Model Triceratops. ****During
Franky’s fight against this Tobi Roppo member,
we get yet another paleontology lesson when
we learn that Triceratops’ frill can spin
around like a propeller enabling it to fly.
**Hebi Hebi**
Also reptiles, and also quite terrifying,
we have the snake devil fruits.
1. **King Cobra Marigold**
Onto the Hebi Hebi no Mi, or snake models, we
have Marigold’s King Cobra fruit.
2. **Anaconda Sandersonia**
As well as Sandersonia’s anaconda fruit.
Both of these Boa sisters have snake
transformations - fitting for siblings based on
the famous Gorgon sisters of Greek Mythology.
3. **Orochi Orochi**
And yet another Hebi Hebi no Mi model from
Mythology is the Orochi fruit held by…Orochi. This
member of the Kurozumi clan really lucked out on
finding a fruit that shared his literal name. It
allows him to transform into the 8 headed snake,
the Yamato no Orochi. Its bonus effect is
that all of his heads have to be removed for
him to be killed, which lead to not one but
9 satisfying decapitations in the Wano arc.
**Sara Sara**
1. **Axolotl Smiley**
Smiley was a weaponized
gas cloud given life in the form of
an Axolotl. Upon its destruction,
we learned that a devil fruit reincarnates into
another normal fruit nearby upon its user’s death.
**Mushi Mushi**
1. **Beetle Kabu
And interestingly enough,
there are only 3 insect devil fruits in
one piece.** Mushi is Japanese for Bug
and these two mushi mushi no mis are owned by
warriors of the Tontatta. First off is Kabu
with the Beetle fruit.
2. **Hornet Bian**
And then Bian with the Hornet fruit.
**Uo Uo**
1. **Seiryu Kaidou
And** Ironically, Kaidou’s actual
dragon fruit is not a Ryu Ryu fruit, but an Uo Uo
fruit: a fish fruit. His fruit is derived from the
Japanese myth of a carp jumping over a waterfall
to transform into a dragon (Think the Magikarp to
Gyarados transformation from Pokemon). Seiryu, or
the Azure Dragon, is also one of the four sacred
beasts of Chinese Astrology (joined by the White
Tiger, the Red Phoenix, and the Black Tortoise).
**Kumo Kumo**
1. **Rosamygale Grauvogeli Black Maria
The 3rd insect fruit.** Black Maria
seems to have more in common with a Black Widow
spider than the Rosamygale Grauvogeli, However,
the Rosamygale Grauvogeli is an ancient,
extinct spider, which makes this fruit fit
in a lot better with the other ancient
extinct creatures of the beast pirates.
**Single Model Series**
1. **Mole Miss Merry Xmas**
The rest of our Zoan fruits
are single model fruits that only have a single
member or the actual fruit names are unknown.
Starting off the list is Miss Merry Christmas
of Baroque Works who can transform into a mole.
2. **Horse Pierre**
Then we have Pierre, a large pink
bird who ate a horse fruit. This enables Pierre
to transform into an approximation of a Pegasus.
3. **Turtle Pekoms**
Pekoms is a lion mink who can
transform into a turtle. Shell yeah.
4. **Egg Tamago**
Baron Tamago has one of the
more interesting zoan devil
fruits. He begins as an egg man…not like Dr.
Robotnik…just a man in an egg shell. However,
he can transform into a fully developed
egg and become a full-blown chicken.
1. **Minotaur**
The Impel Down jailers all have what
are referred to as “awakened zoans” - they lose
their higher functions and turn into simple-minded
rampaging beasts with immense strength. They are
a minotaur - presumably with a bull devil fruit.
2. **Minokoala**
A koala.
3. **Minorhino**
A rhino.
4. **Minozebra**
And a zebra. These four are contenders for the
first “awakened” fruits we ever saw in the series,
unless we count Chopper’s monster point, which is
currently unconfirmed as a devil fruit awakening.
5. **Spider *unknown* Onigumo
Did i say 3 insects? Well i lied, there are two
more.** Vice Admiral Onigumo of the Marines has
an unknown devil fruit that allows him to grow
several spider-like arms. His name is also the
Japanese name of a variety of spider.
6. **Dalmatian Dalmation**
And Vice Admiral Dalmatian also
has a very on-the-nose name,
as his currently unnamed devil fruit
allow him to transform into a Dalmatian.
1. **Caterpillar Epoida**
And the last insect, Also appearing in the
Summit War is Epoida, an ally of Whitebeard,
who can transform into a Caterpillar
with his unnamed zoan devil fruit.
1. **Minochihuahua Chihuahua**
In a cover story detailing what happened
in Impel Down after the prison break,
we meet the newest jailer -
an adorable Minochihuahua.
1. **Pegasus Stronger**
And the newest Zoan, we’ve met is Stronger,
DocQ’s horse who ate a Pegasus mythical zoan
to gain wings. We’re guessing he’d get along
great with Pierre, our other Pegasus in the
series. Wow - that’s all of the zoans in
the series, but we’re just getting started.
**Logia** Up next is the logia
category. These fruits allow
users to turn into an element as well as
generate seemingly limitless amounts of it.
1. **Smoke Smoker**
The first logia we met
in the series was Smoker the White Hunter,
a prominent marine and rival to Luffy. His
devil fruit allows him to turn into smoke. It
was a perfect first opponent to demonstrate the
intangibility of logia fruit users.
2. **Sand Crocodile**
The first Shichibukai the Straw Hats faced
off against was Crocodile, owner of the
Sand logia. Not only could Crocodile use his
sand to release powerful attacks like Espada,
he also had the ability to drain the moisture
out of anything, rendering his opponents into
dry husks. However, Luffy found that Crocodile
was weak to water and by drenching his hands,
he could land blows against the Warlord.
3. **Flame Ace**
Luffy’s brother Ace wielded the Flame-Flame
fruit or the Mera Mera no Mi. This fruit was
a major plot point in Dressrosa when Doflamingo
offered it as a prize in the Corrida Colosseum
to bait Luffy. In that tournament, Luffy and
Ace’s other brother, Sabo, claimed the fruit.
4. **Lightning Enel**
Enel has one of the most powerful logia fruits
we’ve seen in the series. In addition to the usual
lightning-based powers, we see him striking from
an extremely long range, using his electricity
to power technology, manipulate metals, and even
restarting his own heart. It’s just unfortunate
for him that a rubber man showed up in Skypiea.
5. **Ice Aokiji**
Kuzan’s ice fruit is one of
the few devil fruits we’ve seen that can clearly
impact sea water, despite the sea being a devil
fruit user’s weakness. By freezing the surface
of the ocean, he’s able to bicycle from island
to island. He can also freeze opponents inside
and out and they can be shattered to pieces if
not carefully thawed out.
6. **Darkness Blackbeard**
Blackbeard has one of the most unusual logias -
the Yami Yami no Mi or the darkness fruit. Rather
than his body turning into darkness, he can suck
matter into a black hole. Blackbeard is also more
vulnerable to pain and can nullify the fruit
powers of other devil fruit users he touches.
1. **Light Kizaru**
Borsalino, another Marine Admiral, use the
pika-pika no mi - the light logia. Using his
fruit, he can deliver light speed kicks and fly
from island to island faster than any ship can
travel. Dr. Vegapunk also used his fruit as the
basis for developing Pacifista’s beam attacks.
1. **Magma Akainu**
Sakazuki, the current Fleet Admiral,
wields the magma fruit. Its immense power
burns much hotter than the fire fruit,
which made it possible for him to
kill Ace during the Marineford War.
This is one of the most offensively
powerful fruits in the entire series.
2. **Swamp Caribou**
Caribou is another unique logia user,
like Blackbeard, whose fruit doesn’t follow the
typical logia rules. His swamp doesn’t seem to
be able to generate limitless amounts of muck,
but he does have seemingly limitless storage
inside himself. In his swampy pocket dimension
he can store plenty of meat or even mermaids.
****Caesar Clown’s Gas-Gas fruit has
dominion over an entire state of matter.
He’s able to create various gasses, usually
poisonous ones, but he can also remove the
oxygen in a given area to suffocate opponents.
****Monet, a member of the Doflamingo family,
has a snow-snow fruit. This is a fairly
straightforward logia power. After Monet’s
apparent death, we haven’t seen
a new snow-snow user appear yet.
****One of the Marines’ newest admirals,
Aramaki, showed monstrous strength with
his forest logia. He dominated the remnants of
Kaidou’s crew as well as held the Scabbards at
bay until interference from Shanks. With his
fruit he can fly long distances on a flower,
sap the strength from opponents, and summon a
practical army of plant life to fight for him.
The paramecia category of
devil fruits include…well,
everything else. This is a mixed bag of powers
that are left up to Oda Sensei’s imagination,
but usually fall into two categories. There
are paramecias which manipulate the user’s
body in some way or paramecias that manipulate
the environment or other people in some way.
****Buggy was the first devil fruit user we met
in the series besides Luffy. And now that we
know Luffy actually has a mythical zoan, Buggy is
technically the first paramecia user we met. His
chop-chop fruit allows him to disassemble his
body at will. This makes him immune to cutting
attacks. His separated body parts are also
able to fly, provided his feet stay grounded.
The sube-sube no mi makes Alvida’s
body smooth and slippery. Attacks
simply slide off of this ally of Buggy.
****Mr. 5 of Baroque Works can turn any
part of his body into a bomb. He usually uses
boogers, but for an advanced technique he can
breathe into the chambers of a revolver
for long distance explosive shots.
****Miss Valentine can use her Kilo-Kilo
fruit to alter her own weight up to
10,000 kilograms. She can make herself lightweight
to float in the air on her umbrella, or increase
her weight to dive bomb on opponents.
****Nico Robin’s Hana Hana no Mi,
while being named the flower fruit, doesn’t
have much to do with actual flowers. Instead
she “blooms” parts of her body anywhere
she chooses.Pre-Timeskip, she’d usually
sprout arms on her opponents and break their
backs with her “clutch” technique. However,
after the time skip she’s demonstrated the ability
to create clones of herself, make giant limbs,
and even undergo her Demonio transformation.
****Mr. 3, or Galdino, uses the wax-wax fruit
to generate huge quantities of wax.
The most utility this has seen in the
series is through making keys as well as making
venom-resistant armor for Luffy during Impel Down.
Wapol’s fruit is weird. The munch-munch fruit
allows him to eat anything and then incorporate
the material into his own body. He does this
with stone and metals to fortify himself,
and more horrifyingly, eats his own subordinates
to combine them into one super henchman.
****Mr. 2 Bon-Kurei’s Copy ability allows
him to transform his appearance into that
of anyone he’s touched with his right
hand, making him a master of deception.
****Daz Bones uses his Dice-Dice fruit to turn
any part of his body into blades. This made a
perfect opponent for Zoro who had to learn
how to cut steel in order to defeat Mr. 1.
****Miss Doublefinger’s
Spike-Spike fruit allows sharp
spikes to protrude from any part of her body.
****Iron-Cage Hina’s epithet is very fitting.
Her Ori Ori no Mi, or Bind Bind fruit, lets
her conjure black iron bars to trap criminals.
****Bellamy the Hyena Spring-Spring fruit allows
him to turn his limbs into springs, allowing him
to bounce super quickly around a battlefield.
****Doflamingo’s String-String fruit is one of
the most versatile devil fruits we’ve seen in
the entire series. Doflamingo is an example of
a character who truly mastered his devil fruit
powers. He could use his strings to manipulate
people like puppets, to create clones of himself,
to stitch up injuries to his internal organs,
and that’s just the start. That’s not getting
into super OP teachniques like the Bird Cage.
In addition, the Ito Ito no Mi was the first
example we saw of a Paramecia awakening,
allowing him to turn the very environment
around him into strings as well.
****Foxy the Silver Fox’s Noro Noro
no Mi allows him to fire a beam that
slows down anything it touches.
****Blueno of CP9 is able to make
a door in anything and escape to a sort of
pocket dimension. This makes him a great
asset to Cipher Pol as he’s easily able to get
around undetected and flee a scene unnoticed.
****Kalifa, another agent of CP9, was
given a Bubble devil fruit by Spandam,
that among other things, can make
her opponents extra squeaky clean.
****Captain Very Good’s Berry
fruit lets him turn into balls.
****Captain Shu’s rust fruit can
cause metallic items to rust.
****And Captain Sharinguru’s Wheels fruit
let’s him turn his arms and legs into wheels.
****Perona’s Hollow-Hollow fruit allows her to
summon ghosts called Negative Hollows, which make
anyone they pass through “negative”. She can also
leave her body to float around in spirit form.
****Brook’s Revive fruit brought him back to life
as a skeleton after his death. For a long time,
that seems its only power, but now he’s
gained the power to manipulate his soul,
the souls of others, and summon
ice powers from the depths of hell.
****The former warlord Gecko Moria used his
Shadow-Shadow fruit to separate people’s
shadows from their bodies and then place
them inside zombies under his control.
****The Clear-Clear fruit first
owned by Absalom and now by
Shiryu allows the user to turn invisible.
****Bartholomew Kuma’s Nikyu-Nikyu no Mi or
Paw fruit allows him to repel anything, whether
that’s an attack, a person, or even an intangible
concept like pain. He can use it to transmit
people at high speeds all across the world.
****Eustass Kid has the power of magnetism,
allowing him to manipulate metals. After losing
his arm, he uses his fruit to create a metallic
replacement. With his devil fruit awakening,
he can also make his opponents magnetic.
****Trafalgar Law has the Ope-Ope no Mi,
which lets him create a “room” in which he
can manipulate just about anything. He can
remove people’s body parts, their hearts, swap
their personalities, trade places with objects,
and attack opponents internally. This fruit
also has a special ability to grant someone
eternal life at the cost of the user’s
life with the immortality surgery.
****Capone Bege’s Castle fruit turns him into a
Castle Man. He can shrink down his crew who can
act as an army inside of him, as well as transform
into a full size castle with tank treads.
****Basil Hawkins’ straw-straw fruit lets him
use straw creatures as voodoo dolls connected
to other people’s life force, allowing damage
done to himself to be inflicted on other targets.
Scratchman Apoo’s Tone-Tone fruit has
the power to transform his body parts
into musical instruments. Anyone who can hear
his music can be harmed by the sound waves.
Boa Hancock’s Love-Love fruit allows her to
turn anyone who is attracted to her into stone.
The former warden of Impel Down,
Magellan, has the Venom Venom fruit,
which is an interesting paramecia. It’s
similar to a logia in that he can conjure
seemingly limitless amounts of his toxic
goo, but he can’t turn into it himself. It
has the terrible side effect, however,
of giving him terrible stomach problems.
Emporio Ivankov’s Hormone devil fruit allows
them to use hormones to all sorts of effects.
The most common usage of the fruit is change
the sex of themselves or others or giving an
adrenaline boost so that the recipient
can overcome fatigue and keep fighting.
The snip snip fruit allows
Inazuma to transform his
arms into scissors that can cut most materials.
The Quake-Quake fruit first owned by Whitebeard
and then Blackbeard is said to be a fruit with the
power to destroy the world. It creates powerful
earthquakes, but its power can also be localized
to the user’s fist for an earth-shattering punch.
Jozu earned his nickname with his devil fruit,
which allows him to turn his body into diamond.
A Whitebeard ally who only appeared
briefly, Blamenco, uses a pocket-pocket
fruit to develop pockets on his body.
Vice Admiral Tsuru has one of the weirdest
devil fruits of the whole series. Her Woshu-Woshu
no Mi allows her to literally clean evil away from
someone. She can wash her opponents “leave them
out to dry” - people affected by her ability fold
like clothing and get strung up on a clothesline.
Shiki the Gold Lion may not have appeared in the
One Piece timeline, but he and his
fruit are both canon despite mostly
being featured in the Strong World film.
His Fuwa Fuwa no Mi allows him to levitate
himself as well as any other non-living object.
Vander Decken IX also has a peculiar devil fruit.
His Mark Mark fruit allows him to mark someone
with his hand. From that point on, any object
he touches or throws with that hand will seek
the target until it hits them or an obstacle.
Kinemon’s Garb Garb fruit allows him to make
clothing. It’s perfect for disguising people,
however it would be nice if he had people
to disguise who could last more than five
minutes without blowing their cover.
Sugar. This Doflamingo family member
has by far one of the most broken fruits in
the entire series. Sugar can turn anyone she
touches into a living toy with her Hobby Hobby
fruit. Moreover, she can create a contract
with this toy that they are powerless to
disobey. Finally - and here’s where it
gets way too OP - everyone immediately forgets
that the person turned into a toy ever existed.
Baby 5, another Doflamingo family member,
can turn any part of her body into any
weapon she chooses with her Arms Arms
fruit. Presumably because turning them
into actual arms was already taken by Robin.
Buffalo’s Spin-Spin fruit allows him to spin
any part of his body like a propeller, which
he uses to fly. We’re just getting started
on Donquixote Family devil fruits, too -
His crew has a LOT of devil fruit users.
Trebol, the grossest character in One Piece,
is such a low quality individual that his
devil fruit name in Japanese is literally the
Beta Beta no Mi.This translates into the Sticky
Sticky fruit which produces massive quantities
of sticky mucus. He can use it as projectiles
and even wears a cloak made out of it to give the
appearance that he’s much larger than he actually
is.The mucus is also extremely flammable.
Admiral Fujitora has a gravity fruit powerful
enough to rain down meteors on his opponents.
Bartolomeo can cross his fingers to create
powerful barriers, which he can also send
flying for an offensive assault. He can also
manipulate the shapes of his barriers
to create things such as staircases or
surround his fists for a bari bari no pistol.
Leo the Tontatta’s Stitch-Stitch fruit allows
him to sew just about anything.
Viola’s Glare-Glare fruit lets
her see at amazing distances and even
through walls. Confusingly, she can also
fire giant projectile whales from her eyes.
Giolla’s Art fruit lets her transform things
into works of art. Often, her works will resemble
famous art pieces from the real world, such as
Brook turning intoEdvard Munch’s The Scream.
The jacket jacket fruit is one of the weirdest
fruits in the series with probably among the
least actual utility. It allows someone to
wear the user like a jacket, at which
point the user can pilot their body.
Gladius’s Pop-Pop fruit allows him to expand and
rupture any part of his body in an explosion,
which leaves himself unharmed. He can also
cause inorganic objects he touches to explode
as well. His power is extremely similar to the
Bomb-Bomb fruit, with some minor differences.
Senor Pink, the most hardboiled
member of the Doflamingo family,
uses the Swim-Swim fruit to
swim through matter as if it
were water. This power is now used
by the Seraphim modeled after Jinbe.
Speaking of powers similar to
those of Baroque Works members,
Machvise’s Ton-Ton fruit is extremely similar
to Miss Valentine’s Kilo-Kilo fruit. The only
difference is…Machvise can increase his weight
far beyond Valentine’s 10,000 kilo limit.
Another executive of the Donquixote Family,
Diamante uses the Ripple-Ripple fruit to
make objects or himself ripple like a flag.
Pica uses the Stone-Stone fruit to meld his body
into any stone structure and manipulate it freely.
Depending on how much stone he has available,
he can become absolutely massive, hiding his
real body within the stone. During Dressrosa,
he uses this power to dramatically
shift the landscape of the island.
Kanjuro’s Brush-Brush fruit
allows anything he draws to come
to life. RIP Ryuunosuke - you were a real one.
Doflamingo’s brother, Rosinante, ate the Nagi Nagi
no Mi or the Calm-Calm fruit. This allows him to
create a bubble of complete silence where nothing
can be heard. This seems like it wouldn’t have
much utility, but as Law’s flashback showed us,
it can be great for stealth.
The Tontatta Princess
Mansherry’s Heal Heal fruit has the power
to instantaneously heal any physical injury.
Big Mom’s Soul fruit has got to be one of the most
intriguing fruits in the entire series. With it,
she can put part of her soul into any inanimate
object to bring it to life as a “homie.” She can
also, though, rip the souls from other people.
The citizens of her kingdom willingly give part
of their life force to her in exchange for
the Yonkou’s protection, but she can also
take it forcefully from anyone who fears her.
Brulee’s Mirror fruit lets her travel through a
“mirror” world, a sort of parallel dimension that
connects seemingly every mirror. Other people can
also travel into the mirror world provided
they’re touching Brulee. She can also use
her mirror powers to turn into a mirror image
of an opponent as well as to reflect attacks.
Perospero, Big Mom’s eldest son, uses his
candy fruit to create and manipulate candy
into any shape he desires. It can be a
gooey and syrupy or it can be hardened.
Cracker, one of Big Mom’s Sweet Commanders,
uses his Biscuit Fruit to create super hard
biscuit soldiers. He can control an army
of them as well as wear them as armor.
Galette’s Butter fruit, you guessed it,
let’s her conjure and manipulate butter.
Mont d’Or is one of the rare Big Mom crew members
whose power doesn’t involve food. His Baku Baku no
Mi allows him to control books and this manifests
in a lot of different ways. He can fly by standing
on floating books, but he can also trap enemies
inside story-based illusions, as well as imprison
and preserve people within the pages of his books.
And now we come back to the food. Opera’s fruit
is a lot like Galettes, but
with Cream instead of Butter.
Smoothie, another Sweet Commander, has the
Wring-Wring fruit, which allows her to juice
just about anything - including giraffes.
Pudding’s Memo-Memo no Mi allows her to
freely manipulate memories. When she uses
her power, people’s memories will appear
like film reels which she can cut and edit.
Katakuri made the perfect opponent for Luffy
during Whole Cake Island because his Mochi fruit
shares a lot of similarities to rubber. Mochi,
too, is stretchy, but it could do a
whole lot of things that Luffy’s body
couldn’t since he was able to generate large
quantities of mochi. Unlike other paramecias,
Katakuri can also change his body into mochi,
making his fruit a “special paramecia”,
one with the properties of a logia. The key
difference seems to be that Mochi is a man-made
object rather than an naturally occurring element.
Daifuku’s Hoya Hoya no Mi, or Puff Puff fruit,
lets him rub his tummy to summon a powerful
halberd wielding genie to fight for him.
Charlotte Oven uses his Heat-Heat fruit to
heat up his own body. Through touch, he can
then transfer the heat to opponents or objects.
Oven has one of the few fruits that’s been seen
to directly affect the sea when he boiled
part of the ocean to attack the Sun Pirates.
Streusen ate the Cook-Cook fruit and is able
to turn any inanimate object into edible food.
Charlotte Newshi can combine with his nine
decuplet siblings using his Fuse-Fuse fruit.
Morley of the Revolutionaries uses the Oshi
Oshi no Mi or Push Push fruit to push or
mold the ground as if it were made of clay.
Belo Betty’s Pump Pump fruit encourages and
rallies other people to awaken their potential
to fight - a perfect power for a revolutionary.
O-Tama’s Kibi Kibi no Mi allows her to pull
“dango” from her cheeks. When fed to an animal,
they make the animal completely loyal to
Tama’s command for one month. This power
also works on Smile fruit users. This power
is largely inspired by the Momotaro myth,
wherein the hero feeds Kibi Dango to
three animals that help him on his quest.
Kozuki Oden’s wife, Toki, traveled to
the present day from the Void Century
using the power of her Time-Time fruit. This
fruit allows her to travel in time, but only
forward into the future. She can also bring
others along with her on her journey in time.
Shinobu’s Ripe-Ripe fruit allows her to age
objects or even people such as with Momonosuke.
However, she is unable to reverse the effects.
Raizo the ninja uses his Scroll-Scroll fruit to
contain matter or energy within a scroll
and then release it at will. He’s been
seen to do this with huge amounts of
water and even Kaidou’s blast breath.
Blackbeard’s crew mates recently
revealed some new devil fruits,
however not much is known about their full
capabilities at this time. Jesus Burgess’s
Muscle fruit gives him immense physical strength.
Blackbeard’s sniper, Van Auger, can use the
Warp Warp fruit to teleport himself or objects.
Doc Q uses a Disease fruit to spread illness…or in
the Heart Pirates’ case to spread mass sex-changes
due to a pun on Malady and M’Lady.140. Brain
VegapunkThe most recent devil fruit revealed
as of this writing is Vegapunk’s brain fruit,
which lets him store an unlimited amount
of knowledge inside of an ever-growing
brain. His brain has become so large, in fact,
that he has to house it outside of his head.
However, we’re still not quite to the end of
our list because there are a handful of powers
that we know come from devil fruits but we still
haven’t gotten confirmation of the fruits’ names.
Jewelry Bonney’s fruit allows her to manipulate
the ages of herself and others. We’re likely to
get a reveal on her fruit very, very soon.
Another supernova, Urouge, uses an unnamed
devil fruit to convert physical
damage on himself into raw strength.
Sanjuan’s Wolf immense size comes from a devil
fruit as well.144. ?     LafitteLafitte
has an unknown devil fruit that
is likely the source of his wings.
Karasu the revolutionary also has an unnamed
devil fruit. Unlike a zoan transformation that
allows him to turn into a giant raven,
he can become an entire flock of ravens.
And finally, we have Uta. Unlike other
One Piece movie characters like Gild
Tesoro or Douglass Bullet, Uta has been
confirmed as a canon character, sort of,
and that includes her devil fruit,
the Sing-Sing fruit. Using her voice,
Uta can lull people asleep and bring them into
an illusory world that’s under her control.
There you have it - All 146 devil fruits
featured in One Piece so far! But if you
want to know which devil fruits are
the BEST you can check out this video.